bonjour bienvenue à bruxelles au
parlement européen pour un nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo après les
attentats à paris et saint denis et
maintenant qu'on sait un assaut a été
lancé à saint denis à quelques mètres du
stade de france
plusieurs terroristes neutraliser
maintenant que l'on sait que la plupart
des terroristes sont français maintenant
qu'on sait qu'il s'était presque tous
rendus en syrie
maintenant qu'on sait qu'ils étaient
neufs mais que ni leur préparation ni
leur conversation dont été repéré par
les radars du renseignement français
mais aussi belges maintenant qu'on sait
que ces attentats ont été préparés en
belgique à molenbeek plaque tournante du
terrorisme islamiste
maintenant qu'on sait qu'il y avait un
ou plusieurs terroristes qui étaient de
faux demandeurs d'asile syrien arrivé en
europe via la grèce après les attentats
que peut faire l'europe c'est bien le
sujet de européenne aujourd'hui je vous
propose de commencer cette émission avec
cette image
moment solennel et beaucoup d'émotion
aussi les députés ainsi que le personnel
du parlement européen ont entonné la
marseillaise et ont respecté une minute
de silence à bruxelles comme vous le
voyez pour rendre hommage aux victimes
des attaques à paris président de la
commission européenne jean claude
juncker la haute représentante de
l'union pour les affaires étrangères
frédéric hamon guérini est le secrétaire
d'état français chargé des affaires
européennes harlem désir
étaient également présents lors de la
cérémonie le message de martin schulz le
président du parlement européen dans la
douleur nous européens sommes aux côtés
du peuple français
alors avec vous on va essayer de
comprendre s'il ya eu des erreurs des
faiblesses ou une impuissance européenne
direction molenbeek plaque tournante du
terrorisme islamiste
des arrestations liées aux attentats de
paris ont eu lieu dans cette banlieue
bruxelloise connue pour avoir abrité de
nombreux terroristes
françois goulard
molenbeek tous les belges connaissent le
nom de cette commune de la banlieue de
bruxelles et les arrestations qui ont eu
lieu dès le lendemain des attentats de
paris ont conforté sa réputation cette
ville très pauvres touchés de plein
fouet par le chômage est une des bases
européennes du terrorisme islamiste
c'est une commune d'abord qui est une
commune relativement populaire en tout
cas pour certains de ses quartiers avec
une population issue de l'immigration
qui est à peu près de 50% en moyenne et
dans cette population une frange
radicale pas très importante on parle de
quelques pour cent mais réel et depuis
des années c'est à dire depuis 20 ou 30
ans on a donc vu s'installer à nolan bec
des gens qui sont devenus des espèces de
chef de file de l'islamisme radical
non seulement de lui en europe la figure
la plus connue de ces islamistes de
molenbeek
c'est lui abdelhamid about chef de la
cellule terroriste de verviers démantelé
en janvier 2015
il est d'ailleurs impliqué dans la
préparation des attentats de paille
mais la liste ne s'arrête pas là le
français mehdi né mouche l'auteur de l'
attaque contre le musée juif de
bruxelles en mai 2014 est passé par
molenbeek
tout comme le jeune marocain ayoub el
khazani qui a mené l attaque dans le
thalys en août dernier face à ce foyer
de djihadistes le gouvernement belge
assure qu'il va frapper fort au look
back up je vais faire le ménage à
molenbeek
je vais regarder pourquoi ça ne va pas
là-bas et comment on peut faire pour
arranger les choses
ça ne peut plus durer il faut trouver
une solution à ce problème problème
en paca le problème de la radicalisation
ne concerne pas que molenbeek
mais toute la belgique le pays produit
le plus de combattants islamistes
d'europe dans ce petit état de 11
millions d'habitants 494 jihadistes ont
été identifiés par les autorités dont
272 sont en irak ou en syrie et 134 sont
revenus autant de menaces potentielles
pour la belgique mais aussi pour
l'europe
alors nous ont joints sur ce plateau
sylvie goulard bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputé membre de l'alliance des
démocrates et des libéraux un élu sous
les couleurs du modem vous vous réclamez
la création d'un mba européens
on y reviendra en face de vous philippe
lambertz eurodéputés belges du groupe
les verts on vient de voir le sujet de
françois goulard des attentats à paris
mais des hordes qui seraient venus de
belgique et de syrie est ce que la
belgique est une plaque tournante du
terrorisme islamiste c'est clair qu'il y
à des cellules terroristes qui réside en
belgique ce n'est pas ce n'est pas une
grande nouveauté
quand on parle d'un big band des buttes
chaumont là c'est plutôt en france
lorsqu'on parle de certains quartiers de
londres c'est plutôt au royaume uni on
sait que au sein même de l'europe il ya
un certain nombre d'endroits où des
cellules terroristes ont prospéré les
attentats de 2001 était plutôt partie
d'hambourg en allemagne
donc oui ce sont des choses qui existent
et auxquels il faut s'attaquer
ce que je constate c'est que a dans la
plupart des cas observés
les terroristes sont des citoyens de nos
pays
2 que la plupart d'entre aide est connu
des services de police mais que en règle
générale le renseignement dont nous
disposions et n était d'une part pas
communiquer entre les différents
services de police parfois à l'intérieur
d'un même état est certainement entre
les états et par ailleurs qu' il manque
des ressources pour exploiter ces
renseignements c'est à dire mettre ces
gens sous surveillance ce qui me revient
de mes conversations avec les services
de police ce n'est pas que nous manquons
de renseignements mais bien que on
manque de ressources pour exploiter le
renseignement c'est à dire mettre ces
gens sous surveillance iv boulogne à un
manque de coordination entre les
services français les services belges
je crois pas que le problème soit
seulement une question de coordination
faut d'abord expliquer aux
téléspectateurs une chose simple
l'illusion du territoire gouverné par un
état sur lequel il ya une autorité et
les personnes qui sont une menace pour
cet état se trouve sur ce territoire
malheureusement ce n'est plus comme ça
c'est pas une question de le vouloir ou
pas c'est une réalité
les terroristes sont mobiles de même que
le climat est une menace qui vient
d'ailleurs donc l'organisation de nos
états n'est probablement pas adaptée au
monde dans lequel la lutte contre le
terrorisme c'est une compétence
nationale ce sont les états mais qu'est
ce que ça veut dire vous pouvez répéter
juridiquement chez une compétence
nationale et vous avez
200 morts à paris comme le week-end
dernier donc moins ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas de défendre des structures
juridiques c'est de trouver des
solutions
il est évident que nous pourrions aller
bien au delà de la coordination qui est
bien sûr la première étape mais chacun
sait que la coordination ne marche pas
bien
il ya même pas de bonne coordination
parfois entre les différents services de
police d'un même pays
donc ce qu'il faut c'est franchir un
certain nombre d'étapes mais de la
confiance pour que l'information
disponible circulons réfléchir aux
moyens nous avons collectivement voulu
donner la sécurité
tous ces gens qui maintenant font le
virage sécuritaire en février 2013 quand
le budget européen a été adopté pour les
sept années qui viennent est-ce qu'ils
ont placé la sécurité le terrorisme en
tête de leurs priorités non on a fait
quoi on a fait un budget du passé dans
lequel l'essentiel c'est la politique
agricole commune et les fonds
structurels
donc il ya un jour où il faut aussi
assumer que si on veut faire des choses
ensemble au niveau européen il faut des
moyens juridiques et des moyens
matériels et financiers
revenons sur la belgique et l
organisation non gouvernementale la plus
importante du monde a pas de
gouvernement pendant un an est ce que ça
pas jouer en ce moment dans ce manque de
coordination des polices non je ne crois
pas ou de cao minh question des
informations je vous rappelle que la
belgique a toujours eu un gouvernement
simplement pendant 500 jours on a eu un
gouvernement en affaires courantes qui
ne veut pas dire pour autant que les
services de police ne fonctionnait pas
que la justice ne fonctionnait pas dans
ce pays maintenant de nouveaux avons
nous mis suffisamment de moyens sur la
surveillance de ces individus qui sont
connus des services de police qui sont
revenus ce que je constate c'est que
même l'administration municipale et la
zone de police de molenbeek n'a pas
toujours les informations sur les gens
qui sont revenus d'irak parce que ces
informations sont détenues par la sûreté
de l'état
un autre service de police en belgique
et que comme le disait sylvie et bien
parfois les information ne circule pas
vraiment très bien entre les différents
services et donc la belgique n'a pas été
laxiste dans sur le coup est-ce qu'elle
a été laxiste en tout cas elle n'a pas
mis les moyens suffisants pour exploiter
les renseignements dont on disposait à
nouveau nous avions le renseignement il
fallait peut-être l'exploiter manière un
petit peu plus ambitieuse mais là je
pense en effet qu'il nous faut peut-être
une sorte de police fédérale européenne
si nous voulons pouvoir s'attaquer à une
menace qui est qui nous touche tous en
europe
alors on va essayer de répondre à cette
question comment l'union européenne l'ue
tels contre le terrorisme
l'europe elle a des outils revue de
détail et ont réagi juste après
en europe la lutte contre le terrorisme
reste avant tout une compétence
nationale
mais face à la recrudescence des
attentats une coordination européenne a
été mise en place à voici les principaux
outils de l'europe dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme
le système d'information schengen à ce
fichier informatique européen permet aux
services responsables des contrôles aux
frontières policiers et douaniers et aux
autorités judiciaires d'un état schengen
de disposer de données sur des personnes
signalées et des objets véhicule
recherché le mandat d'arrêt européen à
la suite des attentats du 11 septembre
2001 la procédure du mandat d'arrêt
européen est adopté pour faciliter
l'extradition de personnes condamnées
d'un état membre à un autre
enfin le registre des passagers aériens
c'est le dossier sensible le pnr été
créés aux états unis à la suite des
attentats de 2001
il s'agit d'un ensemble de données
collectées par les compagnies aériennes
lors de la réservation d'un vol ou de
l'enregistrement
ça marche pour les vols en direction des
états unis
ça ne fonctionne toujours pas en europe
le partage des données des passagers
aériens entre les différents pays
d'europe est toujours freiné ce et
attentatoire aux libertés individuelles
disent les écologistes européens
aujourd'hui
le ton est monté d'un cran face aux
attentats le président français pose ses
exigences à l'europe
il est également impératif que les
demandes que la france a exprimé depuis
longtemps trouvent en europe une
traduction rapide
je pense à la lutte contre le trafic
d'armes à la mise en place des contrôles
coordonnés et systématiques aux
frontières et à l'approbation avant la
fin de l'année 2015 de ce qu'on appelle
le pnr europe 1 européen tout simplement
pour assurer la traçabilité du retour
des djihadistes et les interpeller voilà
les exigences
l'espace schengen ces 400 millions de
ressortissants
avec schengen ces pays ont supprimé les
contrôles systématiques à leurs
frontières intérieures mais impose des
contrôles aux frontières extérieures
40me km de frontières maritimes et 8000
kilomètres de frontière terrestre avec
les attentes à une réforme du dispositif
schengen est actuellement discuté par
les états notamment sur la question du
rétablissement des contrôles aux
frontières nationales
voilà on a vu un peu les outils dont
dispose l'europe dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme il y à une pomme de discorde
le pnr impasse hadjar name record c'est
l'enregistrement des noms des passagers
dans les compagnies aériennes pour
vulgariser cette à ficher nous
permettant de savoir qui prend l'avion
le pnr le parlement européen ferait de
la résistance sur ce projet les écolos
sont pas d'accord françois hollande veut
que ce soit mise en place rapidement que
l'europe se réveille c'est pour quand le
pnr pourquoi ça bloque
sylvie goulard alors d'abord ça ne
bloque pas contrairement à ce qu'on dit
à paris les discussions sont en cours
deuxièmement le parlement européen où la
résistance quand même du parlement
oui mais pour de bonnes raisons et il
faut que chacun assume ce qui a été son
rôle dans cette affaire
l'idée c'est quoi on fait un fichier de
données vous avez vu l'émotion que
suscite une décision de la cour de
justice qui protège nos données le
parlement européen a voulu protéger les
citoyens européens pas dire on ne fait
pas le pnr dire si on fait un pnr si on
fait des interconnexions de fichiers on
a apporté un certain nombre de garant
des protégés de quoi alors c'est une
dalle ips et attentatoire aux libertés
individuelles en droit français comment
dans le droit de la plupart des états
membres toute la collection de données
reposent sur un certain nombre de règles
on ne peut pas constituer des fichiers
pourquoi parce qu'on veut pas faire un
fichier des juifs on veut pas faire un
fichier les arabes on veut pas faire un
fichier des gens qui n'aiment pas telle
ou telle chose
donc c'est un risque majeur pour les
libertés ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas le faire ça veut dire qu'il faut
satisfait quand on va aux etats-unis le
pnr sympa mais les américains peuvent
voter toutes les lois qu'ils veulent ils
ont fait quand un amant aussi chez bien
qu'en france en ce moment il ya des gens
qui veulent faire quand un amour les
américains c'est les américains et
l'europe est souveraine dans ses
décisions d'un libertés publiques
c'est en europe qui a eu la shoah c'est
en europe qu'il faut qu'on fasse
attention à un certain nombre de dérives
encore une fois les négociations sont en
cours le parlement européen avait rejeté
première version la commission
européenne pouvait revenir plus vite
avec un texte la france en 2013 pouvait
à ce moment-là venir avec des exigences
donc il ne s'agit pas pour le président
la république d'un pays et encore une
fois ce pays est sous le choc c'est le
mien je comprends sa réaction mais de
fixer les dates aux autres il s'agit de
trouver ensemble un système qui soit à
la fois efficaces pour collecter les
données mais dans lequel il ya un
certain nombre de garanties qui permette
que ça se passe bien pour des pour
éviter que ces fichiers qui serait
récupéré même ne serait ce de manière
frauduleuse puisse servir à des fins qui
ne seraient pas des fins correct
philippe lambert si vous êtes
écologistes c'est votre groupe pac qui
ne veut pas que le pnr écoutez c'est un
fake mon groupe qui pèse 50 députés sur
je pense que ce serait nous faire
beaucoup d'honneur de de nous dire que
nous sommes capables à nous tous seuls
de bloquer à dossiers européens tous les
arguments que sylvie a développées sont
parfaitement fondées
il ya un principe de base en démocratie
c'est la proportionnalité entre la
restriction liberté ici la collecte
généralisée l'information est l'objectif
recherché
la question qu'il faut se poser c'est
ignorions nous la nature fait l'identité
de ceux qui ont commis des actes
terroristes cette année si en france
avançant en espagne en italie en
belgique au royaume-uni etc
la réponse est non ce type étaient
connus donc on ne vient pas me dire
qu'il fallait qu'on puisse les repérer
ils étaient repérés ils étaient repérés
donc le pnr en l'occurrence n'aurait
servi à rien du tout ces types sont
venus en voiture en métro mais pas du
tout par l'avion alors bien sûr il sera
clair l'avion depuis lors il vient de
syrie eh bien on les a repérés donc on
n'a pas eu besoin d'un pnr européen pour
les repérer c'est ce que je constate
et donc on voudrait nous faire croire
qu'en ce qui vous fait peur dans le pays
c'est pas une question faire peur c'est
une question principe payer trouvez vous
normal que toutes les données de tous
les passagers de tous les vols qui
circulent en europe soient collectées
sans aucun mandat judiciaire est fourni
en vrac aux services de police
c'est là quelque chose qui en fait est
complètement disproportionnée par
rapport à l'objectif recherché à nouveau
quand je discute avec des policiers qui
sont actives sur le terrain ils nous
disent en général
le pnr nous sert à posteriori pour
tracer l'itinéraire des gens et lorsque
nous avons des suspicions c'est sûr des
gens identifiés leurs familles leurs
proches et
nous sommes capables de cibler les
données dont nous avons besoin moi je
n'ai absolument aucun problème pour que
sur une base ciblées et avec mandat
judiciaire les données soient collectées
aucun problème mais nous n'avons pas
besoin de collecter massivement et
généralement les dom est ce qu'on sera
capable de les exploiter si vous les
mois les moins chose qui me fascine
c'est vous voyez le nombre de gens de
millions de gens qui prennent l'avion
donc je crois qu'il faut raison garder
en ce moment où wall a vraiment essayé
de trouver des solutions c'est qu'on est
tombé dans le trop sécuritaire et qu'on
ne réfléchit pas de maintenir un certain
nombre de principes sinon ce sont les
terroristes qui dirait qu'ils veulent
nous faire peur si nous paniquons c'est
eux qui gagnent donc dans tous nos pays
ça a été rappelé par philippe lambert
il y à un principe c'est que la police
agit en principe sauf état d'urgence
j'ai soutenu le présent la république
dans sa décision la dans ces
circonstances-là de déclarer l'état
d'urgence mais c'est l'exception
les le principe normal c'est que quand
des opérations de police ont lieu elles
ont lieu sous le contrôle d'un magistrat
d'où la nécessité d'avoir un parquet
européen janvier un instant dans votre
reportage vous parliez du mandat d'arrêt
européen
il se trouve que j'étais auprès du
président romano prodi président de la
commission en 2001 au moment des
attentats du 11 septembre
depuis des mois et des années la
commission européenne européenne disait
d'autant nous de cet outil par exemple à
l'époque et dieu sait si c'était
sensible pour l' affaire dutroux
parce que vous aviez des pédophiles vous
avez les gens qui s'engouffre dans les
brèches de la construction européenne
actuelle qui sont pas les gens
sympathiques terroristes aujourd'hui
pédophiles hier nous plaidions à la
commission européenne pour que ce
dossier avance les etam en disait non si
j'ose dire c'est grâce aux attentats du
11 septembre pour avoir une annonce à
faire pour dire qu'il faisait quelque
chose et alors que ça n'avait aucun
rapport avec les attentats durant sa
planque que les gouvernements l'ont
acceptée alors est-ce que le temps en
temps on pourrait agir en amont avant
qu'il est victime avant qu'ils aient des
personnes qui meurent et lin les
questions qu'il faut se poser c'est on a
besoin de gardes côtes aux frontières
comment les organismes
on a besoin bien entendu de circulation
d'informations pnr et autres comment
l'organisent
on a besoin d'une police fédérale
européenne comment on organise et pas de
toujours ré
agir voire sur réagir aux élèves sylvie
boulard le président la république a dit
qu'il allait évoquer un article 1 du
traité de l'union européenne l'article
42 sat qui prévoit la solidarité des
européens
lorsqu'en tapei en fait et agressé
qu'est ce qu'elle va donner cette
initiative concrète alors d'un côté je
n'ai aucun doute que nos partenaires
vont exprimer leur solidarité simplement
il faut se mettre à la place des autres
la plupart des pays d'europe n'ont pas
contrairement à la france la même
tradition militaire et non pas été
frappée récemment par des attentats
aussi cruel il y avait une autre base
juridique dans le traité qui est une
base juridique spécifique pour le
terrorisme
c'est l'article 222 du traité et qui
permettait un jeu institutionnel plus
large c'est à dire c'était pas la france
demande aux autres et à un soutien
militaire c'était l'union européenne
avec la force de ses institutions
avec l'information de ce parlement
l'union européenne est au tour de la
france je pense de rôle dans le théâtre
des opérations extérieures elle est aux
abonnés absents un peu mais quand vous
voulez faire si c'est marrant il ya pas
de politique étrangère et de sécurité
et ça c'est un homme politique étrangère
mais une fois vous avez affirmé ça vous
avez dit quoi moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas de réaffirmer toujours les
mêmes choses et je vous en veux pas à
vous c'est quelque chose qu'on entend
partout à paris tenait mais ça c'est un
constat c'est pas un constat qui permet
l'action moi ce que je vous dis c'est
que la france avait le choix entre deux
bases juridiques lune qui est une
coopération entre états l'autre et sur
un plan militaire l'autre qui est une
coopération qui inclut les institutions
sur un fondement de lutte contre le
terrorisme
je dis simplement et sans vouloir
critiquer bêtement le président de
république mais que la deuxième base
juridique me paraissait plus fondées
pourquoi parce que dans les pays dans
lesquels n'y a pas de tradition
militaire dans les pays dans les pays
c'aurait été plus facile plus rassurant
et donc comme ça on aurait pu les amener
à bouger moi mon but c'est de faire
bouger les autres pays c'est pas juste
de leur balancer à la figure vous êtes
des nains politiques et vous voulez pas
avancer parce que ça c'est pas très
constructif
alors dans son discours un martin schulz
a rendu hommage aux victimes des
attentats à paris à saint-denis
mais le président du parlement européen
a mis en garde un qu'on ne fasse pas
amalgame entre réfugiés syriens ou
irakiens et terroriste ou une écoute et
on réagit juste après
les attentats de paris était une attaque
contre notre liberté
une attaque contre nos valeurs
européennes et notre mode de vie une
attaque contre nous tous dans la douleur
nous européens sommes aux côtés du
peuple français
nous sommes unis nous ne nous laisserons
pas empoisonnée par le veinard de ces
criminels si nous suspectons tous les
réfugiés de syrie alors nous confondons
victimes et meurtrière car les réfugiés
cherche précisemment chez nous en asile
contre la barbarie de ces assassins
alors on a découvert après les attentats
qu'un ou plusieurs terroristes étaient
deux fous demandeurs d'asile syrien
arrivé en grèce via henry en europe via
la grèce est ce que le risque de voir
des terroristes partager le trajet des
migrants venus de syrie et d'irak est
réel ou 7 un fantasme philippe lambert
ce alors première chose il faut raison
garder on a trouvé à passeport on ne
sait pas si ce passeport est vrai ou
faux peu à porto que ne sautons pas aux
conclusions
est ce qu'il est possible à des gens mal
intentionnés de s'infiltrer dans un flux
de réfugiés
la réponse est oui est il possible à des
terroristes d'arriver en europe sans
passer par là la réponse est 10 fois oui
parce que pour à une personne suspectée
d'être passé par le canal des réfugiés
ce qu'on constate c'est que tous ceux
qui ont commis les attentats à nouveau à
bruxelles à paris à londres à madrid
sont les gens qui vivaient ici qui sont
partis en syrie qui sont revenus non pas
par un afflux de réfugiés parce qu'à
l'époque il n'existait pas mais bien par
des voies tout à fait normal donc qu'on
s'imagine fait s'imaginer que en mettant
une barrière à l'accès des réfugiés en
europe
on va régler le problème c'est à nouveau
se mentir et comme le disait s'il
tout à l'heure et bien dans des
situations comme celle-ci ce qu'on
constate c'est que bien souvent les
gouvernements veux simplement donner
l'impression qu'ils font quelque chose
j'appelle ça de la gesticulation et donc
donner l'impression qu'on règle le
problème en en faisant des déclarations
outrancières c'est ce qu'on entend en
pologne et ailleurs ou en prenant des
mesures en prônant des mesures qui en
fait ne sont pas des réponses aux
problèmes et à nouveau je voudrais
vraiment comme sylvie plaidé pour que
nous gardions raison que nous essayons
de regarder ce qui n'a pas concrètement
marché et de nous faut c'est
principalement l'exploitation du
renseignement plutôt que la question des
réfugiés
justement angela merkel et françois
hollande avait demandé à la création de
hotspots de centres de regroupement dans
les pays où les réfugiés arrivent pour
précisément les enregistrer pour savoir
qui est véritablement demandeurs d'asile
qui migrants économiques et qui a
éventuellement terroristes en puissance
est ce que cette politique se concrétise
sylvie goulard
d'après les informations que j'ai moi je
ne suis pas dans ces hotspots mais il me
semble bien que les allemands font une
différence à mon avis justifiée entre
des personnes qui sont qui ont été
obligés de quitter des territoires en
guerre je rappelle qu'en syrie la
situation est effroyable que les troupes
de l'isis justement font des exactions d
exécution et on devrait un peu moins se
polariser sur nos morts toutes les
victimes sont des gens à défendre donc
les femmes yézidie qui ont été violées
réduite à l'esclavagé sexuel et c'est
dans ces régions là sont des victimes
donc d'abord ces deux sont des zones
dangereuses ces gens là ont une urgence
il est évident que si en passant par la
serbie l'albanie etc
se rajoutent des personnes qui bon
veulent simplement améliorer leur vie
mais ne sont pas menacées dans leur
existence il faut arriver à faire
quelque chose d'assez abominable qui
intrigue mais il faut quand même y
arriver est en tout cas l'allemagne est
fermement décidé ensuite là encore moi
je suis toujours prudente parce que
comme l'a dit philippe on peut promettre
aux gens qu'on va arriver à faire des
choses et puis une fois que les
émissions vont se calmer moi ce que
j'espère si vous allez faire des
émissions sur la réponse européenne dans
la durée où on sera dans sin est là pour
ça commencera dans un an mais oui mais
c'est important parce qu'on a bien vu
après charlie on a toute une vague
d'émotion démission et après le sujet
repasse au deuxième plan donc il faut
arriver à faire ça il faut renvoyer
éventuellement dans des pays sur les
gens qui viennent de pays sûrs et il
faut aussi trouver une solution à la
fois diplomatique et militaire pour que
ce gigantesque camp d'entraînement
qu'elle a six
ils ne continuent pas à former les gens
qui viennent chez nous mais il ya quand
même une problème qu'on ne peut pas
pardon est ce que ce sont ces problèmes
c'est ces attentats ne posent pas la
question du du contrôle des frontières
est ce qu'on va revenir en arrière
chilienne revenir aux contrôles aux
frontières intérieures n'ont pas écouté
savourer ça aurait si je ne sais même
pas si c'est matériellement possible vu
les flux de camions qui passent entre le
luxembourg et la france vous avez 70
milles journalier ce qui se passera
c'est qu'au bout d'un moment les lèvera
ces contrôles donc il est beaucoup plus
efficace encore une fois comme je les
dis de créer pourquoi il ya des
conséquences économiques désastreuses au
sens économique la durée hier soir
j'avais une amie belge qui était allé
voir sa mère qui m'a dit qu'elle allait
me ou 1h30 à franchir la frontière
française
parce que les fermes et parce qu'il ya
des contrôles entre l'italie et la
france donc encore une fois ce sont des
mesures qu'on peut comprendre dans une
situation exceptionnelle pour traquer un
individu à long terme il ya une autre
question via une autre question moi que
je veux soulever c'est qu'il ya aussi un
échec de nos relations avec les
populations musulmanes de nationalité
française belge et c'est qu'ils vivent
sur nos territoires ce qui se dit dans
certaines mosquées n'est pas compatible
avec les règles de ces pays
c'est pas un jugement de valeur c'est
profondément juridique de même que on a
à s'attaquer dans ces mosquées
écoutez il ya une vidéo qui circule sur
youtube je sais pas si l exacte ou pas
on voit un imam à brest l'imam de presse
voilà un dire à des enfants que la
musique est satanique et on voit bien le
lien si vous mettez dans la tête
d'enfants de 10 ou 12 ans que parce
qu'ils écoutent de la musique qui vont
se transformer en cauchemar en singe
dans quelques années vous aurez
peut-être des candidats allaient porter
la mort au bataclan
la musique est une activité pacifique
qui dans nos pays est autorisée c'est en
plus un des arts les plus beaux que nous
ayons il faut que nous clarifions ce
genre de questions et je suis sûr
personnellement que l'immense majorité
des musulmans évidemment ne voit pas
dans la musique l'objet d'une
transformation en saint jouan cochon
mais comment avons nous laissé ces
gens-là proliférer et et pouvoir donner
leur discours en toute quiétude dans nos
lieux de culte encore une fois la
liberté de culte est temps aussi garanti
en france mais s'il faut permettre sans
aller jusque là qu'est ce que je
constate c'est que nous sommes tous
horrifiés est vraiment revenu
jusqu'au tréfonds notre en voyant les
images des attentats de paris mais
souvent dans dans notre population
d'origine musulmane
nous avons à ce moment là des jeunes qui
nous montre les images de femmes
d'enfants de civils tués par des
bombardements à gaza au yémen en syrie
en irak en afghanistan et en effet
s'imaginer qu'on peut faire la guerre
propre c'est évidemment une vaste
fumisterie mais là sur schengen ou
penser qu'on va revenir en arrière qu'on
va fermer en docteur fermer les
frontières comme ces demandes et on voit
bien qu'il y a énormément gesticulations
dans ce sens là je pense tout comme
sylvie que ça n'est pas une réponse ce
qu'il faut lehman aurait fait ce pour
quoi
mais lorsque vous allez en paix chez 70
mille personnes travaillent au
luxembourg d'aller travailler et que ça
m'empêchera pas un cinglé de passer avec
une calèche sont un vrai sujet cécilia
efficace même si on peut rêver d'arrêter
tous les gens qu'est ce qu'on va faire
on va durablement empêcher tout tout
mouvement population et puis si un jour
il ya un nid de de djihadistes à
toulouse on va qu'est ce qu'on va faire
on va en cercle et toulouse on va
empêcher les gens d'aller de toulouse à
paris
ça n'a aucun sens n'ont par contre il
faut absolument mettre des moyens dans
l'identification des suspects et dans
leur mise sous surveillance je suis
désolé soyons ciblé ciblons ceux qui
sont véritablement les adversaires et
mettons les sous surveillance et plus
pour les empêcher de nuire ce que la
tunisie pourrait même avoir moins de
moyens pour surveiller les gens qu'il
faut sur l'île de man c'est vraiment
super s'assurer rit énormément de gens
qui eux sont totalement inoffensives
sylvie goulard philippe lambert merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation elle
vous propose de terminer avec une note
de violon après les attaques terroristes
qui ont semblé ensanglanté paris le
parlement européen a rendu hommage aux
victimes habitant les eurodéputés à se
recueillir durant un adagio de jean
sébastien bach jouée par une violoniste
ukrainienne écoutez bonne suite des
programmes
bye bye
i
et
mais